Okay, so before we move on and start looking at interior lighting, I wanted to go ahead
and show you some of the additional tools that Unreal Engine has that might help you
when lighting a scene.
So the first of which is going to be changing your view mode.
So when debugging and trying to figure out what's actually going on, it can be handy
to change your view mode to different modes, for example, to an lit mode where you're actually
able to see just perfect color data information.
You also have modes like Light and Only, which allow you to just see the lighting with no
reflections or normal information, just what the light itself is doing.
You also have Detail Lighting, which includes reflections and normal information.
These are some of the view modes that essentially can be helpful when trying to devote what
might be going wrong or just help you get that extra little nudge where you need it
to get the right realism for your scene.
I'm going to go back to lit mode.
And another one of the things that I want to touch on is the scalability tools.
These are usually designed to bring stuff down in quality if your machine's struggling
with rendering the scene.
However, for architectural engineering and construction industries, we might want to
crank these all the way to the top since usually we have high-end PCs.
So I'm going to go to Settings here.
And under Engine Scalability Settings, I'm going to set everything to cinematic.
So you'll see you'll get a little quality bump right there, which is really handy.
One other thing I wanted to show is sometimes you'll notice that by any accidental change
that you might have done, you'll be missing certain things from the scene.
So the show flag here might be handy.
Say, for example, you accidentally turned off anti-aliasing.
All this information is all the way over here in the Show tab.
And here you can also turn on stuff like motion blur and things like that if you so desire.
Now one last thing that I wanted to check in order to get that extra little bit of performance
out of the engine is if you go to Window and Project Settings, sorry, Edit Project Settings,
we're going to go to the Render tab again.
We're going to change our G-Buffer format.
So we're going to Render in.
This time I'm looking for the Optimization tab.
So I'm going to scroll all the way down.
And here under Optimizations, I'm going to take a look at the G-Buffer format.
I'm going to set this to high-precision normals.
So this will encode the normals in 16 bits per channel, and it will give us higher and
better detail.
Now the next tool I want to take a look at, the Calibration tools.
So sometimes we're going to want to start working from a calibrated scene that's matching
something in the real world.
So what I'm going to do is access the Calibrator.
To do this, I actually need engine content available.
If you missed that earlier on, you could just enable it by going to Settings, Show Engine
Content.
And in here, I'm going to search for Calibrator.
Now with this, I can actually drag in my color calibration tool.
And this essentially gives me a few bits of information and color that I can calibrate
against in the real world.
So an important step to do is to just set the Calibrator to face the sun.
And then what we're going to do is use a little tool called the Pixel Inspector, and we're
going to calibrate this square here, the third gray square from the right, to be perfect
gray essentially.
So in order to do that, all I'm going to do is go to Tools, Debug, Pixel Inspector.
And the way you use this tool is really simple.
You just click the little search button here, and now you hover over the pixel that you
want to sample.
Once you hover over that pixel, you can press Escape to freeze that pixel essentially.
And what we're looking for is this luminance value here, so enter a value of 0.18.
Now mine's already calibrated.
However, if, say for example, your lighting was at 10, you might want to now start adjusting
things to get the right value.
So if we go to Debug once again, Pixel Inspector, we'll find that pixel once again.
And you can see my luminance here is now set to 2.2.
Now usually what you want to do is bring this down to 0.8 with the dominant directional
light and then start adjusting your exposure later on to actually get the right level of
light that you want.
So in order to do this, I'm just going to go ahead and inspect the one that I want,
press Escape, and now bring the strength of my directional light down.
So let's try it with full.
Once again, we can inspect it.
We're at 0.19, so we're close.
So once again, Escape, set this to 3.8, and that's how you sort of hone in on the value
that you need.
So essentially that gives us a, in the linear scale, it creates to 50% gray, but since we
have sRGB going on an HDR, it's something that adjusts the curve of the value.
So illuminance of 0.18 is the correct sort of 50% gray.
So from here, we now want to tweak our exposure.
So to tweak our exposure, we've got a few methods.
If you want to do it just on the viewport, you can go to the Lit tab here and just untick
game settings and start editing the exposure through here.
Now, it's important to know that this only really affects it for the viewport, so it's
not really handy when actually going into the game.
To do that, you actually want to do changes based on the post-process volume.
So I'm going to select that post-process volume.
I'm going to scroll down until I find the exposure settings.
Now, if you're struggling to find it for whatever reason, you can always just use the search
tab.
Search exposure.
In our case, I just found it right there.
So we've got it right here.
So we have three ways of measuring exposure, and you can control them using the post-process
volume, as I mentioned.
So the three modes are auto-exposure histogram, which provides a lot of control with advanced
settings, and it's constructed on a 64-bin histogram.
And it's the default exposure setting the Unreal Engine comes with.
Then there's a basic, if we change this to basic auto-exposure, it provides fewer settings
for us to actually change, and it computes single values by downsampling exposure itself.
And then a manual mode, which actually enables us to change this based on the camera itself.
So in our case, we're going to keep it to auto-exposure histogram.
And essentially, what you want to be changing more than anything is the minimum and maximum
brightness that you have in your scene.
So you can bring these values down or up to suit your needs.
And these will affect how the auto-exposure changes depending on what you're looking at
in the scene.
Now, remember that this has to be set to game settings to see the changes that you're making here.
For me, we can leave them as default.
Or what I like to do is, as I'm working, I like to lock my exposure.
So I set this to one and then this to one.
And once I'm happy with the way everything feels, I can then maybe go to the default
or edit them slightly.
Because if you can see here now, we'll get eye adaptation to adjust for the darkness
on the inside here, which blooms out the outside.
So I generally like to work with this set to one and one to lock it in.
And then go from these values to edit things afterwards.
So I could go to minus five and ten instead so that it never goes that bright or that dark.
So it's something for you to play with and get the right look for your scene.
But I just want to go over these additional tools before we jump into going to artificial
lighting, which we're going to go ahead and do next.